and here we go
malik what's up
you are first
hello everybody
welcome back welcome back to the watch
parties
all right sound is good what's up
everybody how are we doing
it's been a while
how do i
let's do it's been a while that i don't
know how to do anything
there we go my cat is like yelling like
crazy right now so she wants me to
better
what's up
yes i did dye my hair blonde just so we
could say what if warren was blonde
yes
how is everybody doing i am doing good
thank you all for asking
uh
the hair is temporary i had to bleach it
to diet a different color which i think
is going
um
yes
i didn't really know what to expect how
is
there we go i didn't really know what to
expect um
from an animated series from marvel i
mean i didn't expect it to be bad
because it's marvel and you know
yeah so uh
i liked it
i hope everybody else likes it oh we
should get rid of that
this is just so i can read the comments
on the left side and not have to stare
over here to look at the comments i can
actually look over here there we go
uh
well i'm
those asking how many
episodes
are there
um
i have seen
three episodes
uh this first one i think is like 31
minutes long something like that 30
they're all like 31 minutes i think one
is 30 one's 31 one's 32 the three
episodes that i've seen
and then
uh
i think there's i think there's ten but
recently like collider somebody said
there was only nine but when i was in
the press conference they said ten
so i'm a little confused
uh oh what's up joey chaos you're joe
dobber from twitter what's up yeah we
talk all the time on twitter
hello everybody
yes blackpink hoodie i love them
blonde wig wonder uh it's not a wig
not a wig my actual uh my actual hair
trust me because it really hurt to
bleach it i
i i it really hurt my my head to bleach
it uh we're only getting one episode
tonight guys um
from what i've heard only getting one i
would be shocked if we got more than one
really really shocked we got more than
one let's make sure everything is
happening right now everything's good
yeah sound looks good everything looks
good i'm glad to be back i'm glad
everybody's back we get 10 well okay
sorry
we get nine or ten episodes of these
uh and i'm excited i'm really really
like really excited for all of them so
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah people have been saying that like
do my eyebrows too but i i don't want to
um i don't remember there being a
post-credits scene guys uh
i don't believe there is actually i
could check right now hold on
rick kyle jr coming in with super chat
what's up
your color doesn't have what do you mean
it doesn't well it's not out yet we
still got like 15 minutes before it
comes out so wait on that wait on that
rick thanks for the super chat but um
don't don't uh give up hope yet
let's see uh
where am i going here i'll tell you
right now if it has a post credit scene
it does not have a post-credits scene
i just checked on the screener that they
sent me
nope
oh that's chinese
yeah no post credit scene
the ending's pretty cool though um
the ending's pretty cool and i will say
that during the press conference they
they said that
uh captain carter is one of the
characters that is going to be like a
reoccurring character which is cool and
i honestly really liked her in this um
i want her live action which has been
like the rumor right i i really want her
live action so i hope that happens
how are you doing cosmic handsome thank
you infinity shades back with the super
chats i see thank you thank you very
much um
anime fisto theories
you're gonna laugh but yeah there's like
a poster for what if that came out
for like the zombie ones and there's
like people in the background and one of
the guys legitimately looks like
mephisto and a bunch of people are
actually talking about it like on
twitter and stuff and i'm
like is it memphis though
i didn't want to like start i didn't
tweet about it because i didn't want to
start it
but i really sat there and went
this is like i i really did i really
wondered
am i gonna drop an a no way home vid or
when am i gonna drop one um
when there's news uh
i feel you know i feel like sometimes i
get in this like
uh not vibe
like rhythm of doing a bunch of
spider-man videos
and it's always and it's always
funny because like
every now and then i'll do like two
three four spider-man videos in a row
because there's news and then some
people be like why are you doing so much
spider-man news like there's other
things to talk about
and then when i go like four or five
days without posting a spider-man video
i feel like all the comments are like
where the heck like what the heck what's
going on with spider-man i'm like
um
yes this is a variant i am from
a different universe i'm not from 616.
i should have titled it something like
that i didn't realize everyone was going
to think i'm a variant because i changed
my hair i actually didn't think a lot of
people would notice that i changed my
hair i guess i underestimated everybody
porn boner that's who i am a morn boner
rick kyle jr yeah i can't wait for that
one either actually i haven't seen that
one so it wasn't in the first uh first
it wasn't in the first three episodes
i enjoyed
i enjoyed episode one the q here's the
cool thing
it it's cool but like depending on how
you view it it may not be cool
and rick howe jr thanks again for that
super chat um
these
episodes are standalone
episode 1 does not lead into episode two
they have no connection episode two
doesn't lead into episode three episode
three is no connection to
episode two or one and i'm assuming
that's how all of the episodes are going
to be i've only seen the first three
so
it's a different
it's a different um
it's a different viewing
because you know it doesn't connect so
you watch one episode for what it is so
it's kind of cool
uh it's kind of cool uh who's my bias in
blackpink
i feel like that changes all the time i
feel like my bias right now is rose
but jisoo always has like a place in my
heart because she's so goofy and funny
that i just i love her personality so
much but i think right now rose is like
my bias
uh thor love and thunder what to expect
i could do that
it's been a while since uh
it's been a while since we are since
we've talked about thor love and thunder
uh i haven't spoiled anything for people
saying no spoilers um i think it's been
announced by now that these episodes
don't really connect to each other
um they're all standalone episodes
ah
i'm trying to hide from the feds yep
they'll never find me with blonde hair
uh
yeah that's a good that's a good point
somebody was saying is it out by now i
don't see it
i don't see it okay but like i'm
genuinely interested so at the end of
this i really want everyone like if you
leave to watch it on your own come back
because i want to know what people think
about this because i like i talked to
greg from the real rejects like every
day
and i personally really liked the first
episode because i really liked the story
like what if it was captain carter not
steve i actually really liked that story
and i was talking to greg about it and
he was like yeah it was okay
and because you know it's animated it's
very different and you know they don't
connect
to really anything else
so i'm curious to hear what everybody
says
excuse me uh what everybody thinks i'm
really curious um
you know like
did y'all like it did you not of course
obviously after the episode
but uh
yeah any collab with the canadian lad
you know uh we talk every now and then
uh i was trying to help him
uh get some screeners like i get but
unfortunately it's handled by a
different disney department it's handled
the canadian department and i'm in the
us um
i the canadian lad's a great dude uh i
really can't say
enough good things about him uh and we
we always do plan to
collab in the future we've collabed in
the past and uh we will in the future i
i'm actually planning some collabs with
heavy spoilers my man paul
uh
3c
chris over at 3c films
uh and greg for the real rejects and
john that's we always uh
we always talk so those are my guys
those are like there's like my
communities right there this is my peeps
and of course chris over at cosmic
culture he's live right now
uh i feel like i'm
someone asked something
i didn't explode
all right
what's up what's up what's up it's out
it's out it's hot all right let's check
it out
oh i don't see it you guys always
trolling you guys always trolling you
keep me on my toes
a lot of you saying it's out
i'm not seeing it
yeah i don't i don't have it uh i have
collabed with the new rockstars before
um i did some uh rogue theory with them
or two broke their i don't remember how
many uh eric moss is awesome zack who's
uh exec producer over there is really
really awesome dude really nice guy um
they seem to have
their their like group going right now
uh uh so i don't know if there's a new
rockstars collab coming soon but they're
great guys over there
eric boss is the man they i mean they
have to be like the number one channel
right
i mean i would be shocked if they
weren't
so were you surprised about there being
a season two vlokie raquel jr thanks
again for super chat no um i knew it was
coming um
well i should say
i had heard all the reports that i was
coming so
when it was like season two i was like
yes okay yes they were true like all
right
uh it's like i heard it from really
credible people um but at the same time
it's like you never you never really
know it's gonna what's gonna happen so
yeah i was uh
i was happy for it search manually for
it that's actually a good idea good
suggestion
it is out hey thanks for that appreciate
that all right hold on
are we ready fam
oops that was the wrong button that's
the wrong button that's the right button
i did it first try
okay we're about to do it
hey king variant
woof woof that's pretty sweet okay
here we go
what if
captain carter
were the first avenger
uh
here we go
one
two i'll count that three two
one
we started here it goes
i'll go full screen for this
oh i have to mute the desktop audio
where i'm going to get so copyrighted
early screening i didn't see any oh no
no go back no go back i didn't see any
post credit scene
which like these shows don't connect to
anything so why i guess like you know
why would there be a post credit scene
okay uh
i wanna know what everybody thought
um i wanna know i wanna know what
everybody thought about this as i get
chris in here
um
yeah perfect voice yeah so yeah let's
rate i just want to see in the chat guys
uh 1 out of 10 10 the highest one the
lowest
what do you rate this episode
what did you think about the animation
i'm genuinely curious because i you know
i didn't know how people
were gonna
receive this after i saw it you know the
first time um i will say
it gets better the second episode is
better than the third episode it's
better it it gets better uh who was the
watcher the watcher is uatu it's uh
jeffrey wright voicing him and it is uh
uh let's see
who
i think it was schumacher i really do
okay a lot of sixes sevens seven point
fives eight six a lot a lot of a lot of
six oh i got a tin there there we go
good good okay okay
a lot of six out of tens we've got some
tens we got some eights nine
not bad so far i again i will say it
gets better it it it gets better um
i like i think it's a cool concept like
i really do think it's a cool concept of
you know what if uh
i just i can't help but to think that as
we're watching all of this i wish i
could see it
live
like i think captain carter is pretty
freaking cool but
i want her
oh
i want her
i want to see her live
oh
my boy hello i forgot the camera so it's
just gonna be you
okay it's blorin
is that that's what we nicknamed me
lauren
lauren
blonde warren how do i how do i just
make it there we go
full screen
full screen just chris
full screen just chris
everybody here chris
hi guys i'm chris
pulling you up right meow
he ain't got a camera guys so you don't
get to see his beautiful hair is alex
still up she can bring it to me
i mean she's two stories down oh she's
downstairs i thought she might have been
upstairs
there we go say hello to chris everybody
the mirror ali productions
when steve became captain america he
screamed and light was yellow when
carter did it she didn't scream the
light was blue nice hair oh thanks
yeah i actually watched like
uh a bit of
i watched what i needed to watch of
captain america the first avenger today
and yes oh yeah steve yelled ah he's
like no
i could do this and he did it honey
funny enough my favorite part was
actually when she almost ripped bucky's
arm off
by saving him though and preventing him
from becoming the winner soldier because
that's the exact moment where it happens
another universe
what
i like the animation it's not like
modern day pixar no no no no no it's
like a cool like cartoon like yeah old
school cartoon network almost with a
little new new touch
it's smooth
it's smooth
i was kind of worried at first like
what's it going to be like
um and like i just told my chat and
again namir ali thanks for that super
chat i just love my chat it gets better
um
right it gets better hey billy book news
what's up how's it going it's fun
it's fun yeah like that's how you have
to view this going into it because
it's not super serious doesn't connect
to anything else maybe down the line
like a multiverse of madness you know
it'll connect the thing but you gotta
view it for what it is and like episode
two has nothing to do with episode one
episode three has nothing to do with
either episode like none of the episodes
connect
right
is not is not peggy carter in another
one so they're gonna explore peggy
carter in season two again they did say
that they go back to her at some point
in time i don't know
if that's their plans for season two or
if she comes back in an episode
and and something sorry
yeah i mean
what's that go ahead
because i think the big question is um
and i think the answer is yes especially
if we're heading into secret wars
do we get this peggy carter
live action in secret wars i
i hope i hope we get it like daniel rpk
said
multiples of madness
so hoping we get into multiple status um
so yeah let's see let's see what the the
chat doesn't say uh thank you rahul
i'm sorry i can't pronounce that right
uh yeah they have yeah season two is is
confirmed hundred percent they said that
the press conference ice uh they
confirmed that when i interviewed the
director and the writer um
yeah no no problem billy bug go get some
sleep what's up aiden maxwell how's it
going what's up everybody
uh jeff quino thank you for that super
chat he did not like it which is okay
you know i can see how people aren't
gonna like this
uh jeff it the next two get better as
they go on so maybe hold on some hope
but hey if it's not your thing it's not
your thing
i get it i'm always hesitant with
anime
animation i'm always hesitant with like
animated stuff
well here's the big question right did
you feel like you were watching
something from the mcu
um
yes because it's basically captain
america the first avenger with a yeah
but i mean like
as you're watching it you feel like
you're inside
possibly you know the multiverse was
opened by loki and the watcher did a
really cool job of introducing that to
us at the very beginning it's explained
very clearly even at the end as he's
headed out
but does it does it feel like somewhere
in the background of the multiverse as
we see
this is happening or do you feel like
this is just kind of thrown in here
that's the big question i think and fans
who can visualize it that way like this
is actually happening in the background
somewhere in some parallel universe
that's a cool thing to consider
yeah
um
thank you jam 4401 uh i you know
i don't know um
i don't consider these
part of the universe
okay i i i think just because of the the
pure fact that it's animated
but i mean i even like like okay so
everybody knows we've seen these
episodes before so i started right now
before and i even i even said in my
breakdown i was like this does exist in
the mcu because it's like a timeline of
a timeline and that timeline happens to
be animated and like logistically it
makes sense and i'm not arguing all
right but whether or not i feel that
not so much different story yeah not so
much do i feel like it's like
no because again because again we've
seen the first three episodes and we
know they don't connect to each other so
it's like
that makes it kind of almost really not
feel like it but at the same time yes
they are like they are but somewhere in
the multiverse they are they exist at
the mcu not in the main timeline
no but they exist
where was she pulled into i mean
obviously she wasn't pulled into the
main timeline so that was just her
timeline right
well yeah right so it was like her time
again well even when she went through
the tesseract
right that's all her timeline it's her
timeline yeah uh
hold on trying to decide we'll go ahead
no super chat
it's also when steve went to the machine
to get buff from the machine the light
was yellow but when carter did the light
was blue steve skinny boy
yeah maybe uh maybe it's just the fact
that maybe it's because their bodies had
affected differently i don't remember
what color
the serum was
i think blue i think it was blue in the
movie it was blue
in the movie
yeah
okay so
yeah yeah so but good point i'll look at
that thanks for the super chat but yeah
no it it's
they've already confirmed it's canon to
the mcu
right it's just not in the main timeline
it's not in our sacred timeline they've
already confirmed this they've come out
and said yes this is in the
mcu which it should be because i don't
think marvel
should
do
one-off things
no i don't think we need to start doing
that at all i don't
it works for dc because their universe
isn't really put together but i don't
think marvel should do one-off things so
yeah this exists in the mcu just not in
the main timeline
and it also leaves room you know if we
do head the secret war route which i
don't see how we don't for these
characters to show up
oh totally i don't know necessarily that
they will but we could see this exact
version of peggy carter
in secret wars fighting falcon or the
new captain america
yeah i don't know for sure if that's
their plan but i you'd have to think
it's definitely being discussed yeah
i would assume so especially because i
think
i think that's
what it's all leading up to
and it would be really cool
i would like to see the transformation
of her like from animation into real you
know what i mean yeah and i think they
do a fantastic job i think that would be
really cool uh once a sec
uh juaquin fernandez or jacquin
fernandez i'm sorry i'm probably
butchered your name but thank you so
much for the super chat when steve got
blown up
by the train i thought he would have
become winter soldier that would have
been a better idea i think so too i just
think they didn't have time to do that
you know i think the focus was on peggy
because i mean i mean the show is even
called or the title of this show
episode was even called
what was it like what if
peggy carter was captain america i don't
let me yeah what if here oh yeah i have
it right here let's find these while you
do that i do have a super chat
says does that even make sense
that the space stone put her in the
future like please explain it's not the
time
stone um i would argue space and time
are kind of combined you could get sent
to a different universe wherever
this schuma goreth knockoff came from
and um that time could run faster than
the time here you know kind of like when
you talk quantum real time like when
ant-man goes into the quantum realm and
then comes out it was five hours but it
was actually five years
yeah so different timelines have
different time it's kind of like when
you get into the what's that movie
called interstellar oh gosh when it yeah
completely different direction but it
goes into different time and space and
it's like four minutes there's like 40
years on earth it's something kind of
like that space and time do have a very
close
i don't want to try to break it down for
you anybody but there is something there
there's that movie but that's it's
confusing itself
it goes down to that planet right what
if captain carter were the first avenger
that was oh yeah yeah yeah that's what
it's called kim's brook corner thank you
for becoming a member you now have
access to our emotes
everybody who's a member spam your
emotes
and you're getting yeets from lauren
which universe do you come from i don't
know everyone says
yeah people coming in here and telling
me the same thing
but which variant am i am i good am i
bad you're probably
myself
probably
probably i already have what was i next
is what was my nexus event you received
the super soldier serum uh i think i
trusted nobody i should have trusted
it's got to be something cooler like
what was your nexus event like oh it was
sponsored by monster dead of chief right
said
so i became evil
um my next event was i saw the no way
home trailer and didn't tell anybody but
oh man he's the reason we haven't gotten
it yet
looking whether or
whether i have not seen pictures tonight
levi is neither here or there
don't worry about it
uh what i love marvel as well joey cat
warren the conqueror that's me
uh the next episode is a week from right
now
yep yep yep i knew they weren't gonna
release two episodes
no that's okay i actually like the 30
minute episode i don't think it doesn't
feel too short i don't mind it being
short but
i see that
because it's 1 30 in the morning right
yeah right work right now so it works a
little easier when it's that short but
just from a viewer standpoint even the
length because we already know the story
because it wasn't um
too different
it you just fill in those blanks with
what you know gotcha
so it's kind of nice i don't know if
they'll all be that way because there
are some that won't fit like a story we
already know but i don't think we needed
more than 30 minutes no i think it was
it's literally just
i don't think the story changed that
much like
it was pretty
captain carter where captain rogers went
and a few things changed like street
mcgorth popped out out of nowhere and is
that what we're calling that i think it
was schumacher uh they didn't show us
what i thought i
what else would it be
well what's the the logo of hydra could
have been some type of reminder whatever
that is we cut off one head six more
grow back kind of thing
right but a hydra is
to me has like heads on the things that
grow back right because if you cut off a
head you're not a tentacle like you cut
off a head right like oh maybe the head
remember that didn't come out
yeah yeah yeah
that's a hydra yeah that's a hydra they
have heads unlike the things
uh is episode two for t'challa star
lords yes
and it's a really cool episode that's a
tear jerker yeah that's a rough uh it
kind of is a tear jerker it is isn't it
yeah but
it's really cool like the they did a
good job the way
it's a tear jerker because the way they
view the second episode
is
instead of the universe affecting
t'challa he affects the universe like
that's how like
vibrant he is
it's super super cool
it stands out
somebody asked do you like that they
made the show like a cheap rip-off and
that we didn't get any new stuff besides
a few things
i personally think it makes the story a
little easier to follow i also think
it's a good replication of how a small
thing like peggy staying in the room
would change the outcome of a different
universe well you also have to
you have to think story-wise
you like you
you have to follow what if like that's
the whole thing and so in this situation
that's what would have happened
right like that's what if peggy didn't
leave the room
right what and then she becomes captain
america and then she and the war's still
happening right hydra is still out there
like that's still the threat right she's
not gonna run off and go do something
else like that's what has to happen
right so
i will say
the next two episodes are way out there
they don't follow normal at all it's
like nothing you've ever seen in the mcu
they put it's fun it's fun they put
twists on stuff which is really cool uh
so i see a few people
uh asking about the watcher as to the
best of my knowledge
jeffrey wright who's voicing the
characters really famous actor
is playing uwattu which is in the comics
is earth's watcher
he's our solar system's watcher
he stands outside of the multiverses
right
uh there the whole watcher species watch
is like the multiverse um
in our watcher like so the they're not
supposed to interfere but our watcher
has in the comments and he's got
put on track because he's like he like
becomes friends with the fantastic four
so he like warns them about galactus and
stuff like that sometimes and so
eventually gets put on trial and then he
like they ban him
from being a watcher but he like still
watches over earth so they're eventually
like all right you can come back you're
a watcher again but don't interfere but
he kind of still does
yeah yeah yeah i thank you for stopping
by now have a good one yeah i really
want uh
i really want the live action watcher
and yeah we've yeah we've seen the
watchers and guardians of the galaxy
with stanley right
but yeah
no i hope we see this watcher
make an appearance somewhere
because this isn't all the same
multiverse right or is it the same
storyline
what do you mean
so is this watcher jumping us through
different parallels i think it's
different parallel yeah so
different but you know what i mean
different multiple i don't think they're
in the same timeline at all no right so
this entire group of people won't form
the same avengers they're just different
different multiverses so this watcher
could make an appearance in
in the main timeline at some point which
i think would be really cool well i
actually
i'm thinking about the third episode and
i'm not going to say anything because i
don't want to say any spoilers i'm just
trying to think i think
i can see you alicat
um
uh no andrew the third episode is not
zombies
i haven't seen the zombie one it's not
the first three
man i'm trying to think of a very
specific part in the third episode
that might suggest they're part of the
same universe
but i don't think so no no they're not
no because that would make sense no yeah
so i don't uh
yeah um
t
k leth
i don't think people would be that
confused because since it's going to be
the multiverse of madness where like
anything is possible i think it's going
to just be like oh cool and you know
and that universe that's who she is you
know i don't think it'll be that bad
people don't necessarily need to watch
this
um
no if you don't see this it won't be too
too confusing the premise of the episode
with no spoilers um avengers
the premise so vague
captain america if she were peggy carter
no of the third episode oh the third
episode avengers oh yeah
yeah
avengers
surely other people have talked about
homework
yeah the non-avenger the revengers
i know
yeah the show came out we watched it
already um
and it seemed like people i i saw a lot
of sixes
when i asked people what they thought of
it
excuse me um
yeah
it's kind of hard because they haven't
seen the other ones because you can't
really compare this to loki
right
you gotta
oh just the journal the other episode
yeah
if once you see a few episodes you can
start comparing them to each other
obviously if you compare this to to
anything else in the mcu it's kind of
hard to to do that
but i would compare the episodes to each
other
uh no they are not interconnected
um
what if nebula was blonde hoof
then
bl blondullah and blorin
yeah right she'd be she would not be a
single sad robot somebody was super up
in the galaxy probably warren
guys warren loves um karen gillan like a
lot like a lot
she's probably on his top three if i
could date somebody list
i'm scottish
yeah right she's playing on your top
three
top three celebrity crush list
she's pretty up there
put it up there
yeah uh i did not watch all 10 episodes
i watched just the first three
yeah
uh ultramaton
you are correct
in that episode's too cool episode two
is cool
episode two is a lot a lot a lot of fun
i would say episode three
is a cool idea
and not expected
alexa welcome back thank you for the
super chat happy to be back with you
guys i'm happy you're back episodes okay
but definitely keep in an open mind for
next week doesn't feel like i'm watching
them so you totally get it um i don't
know if you can use the whole time but
the next two or next one gets better and
the the third one gets better as well
they get better as they go on again i've
only seen the first three
um
and i figured people would have mixed
the opinions about oh for sure it's
something it's a different pill to
swallow
um no i guess uh warren and i have seen
the first three episodes because we got
them sent early to evaluate and to uh
review but the only the first episode
came out tonight yeah
kim we all loved loki it was a fantastic
i think everybody i think the majority
of people would say loki's their
favorite disney plus show so far
i've heard a few people say one division
but i think the majority of people like
loki was just that good it really was
uh
[Music]
okay i'm seeing a few interesting things
here
what are you seeing so one heard grace
randolph said episode three was her
least favorite
yeah but she also didn't like the
suicide squad yeah so she hated the
squad
and like she hated it
i loved it i'm all about you like what
you like right i never give anybody any
crap or shame for liking something
that's not popular or not liking
something that is popular
i don't care you like what you like i
like weird stuff normal people don't
like too
and i don't like stuff that a lot of
people like so
uh yeah that's just her personal choice
i thought episode three was pretty cool
i thought it was a pretty cool premise
uh i think episode two is my favorite
but i think episode three is better than
episode one
um
i don't know episode three is pretty
cool
i just think
maybe the ending could have thrown her
off i could see how the ending might
throw people off mm-hmm but
it's definitely better than episode one
i think a lot of people are gonna really
like the next episode mr anderson people
should like things it's good
i like that i like that mr anderson
sometimes sometimes life is a little
easier if you just kind of like things
fork how are you doing thank you for
joining we can be nice when people
like or don't like things that
are oh for sure i don't disrespect
populous
i don't people in my comments section
sometimes completely disagree with me on
stuff i say
sometimes they're a little mean and
every time i just be like
thanks for sharing finally
crying but thanks for sharing like i try
because everybody has an opinion and a
thought
and
and i appreciate that you know some
people watch this and think it's a
complete waste of time why is marvel
doing this it's a money grab blah blah
blah i'm looking at as marvel trying out
something new something fresh you know
and and people what do we always say
whenever warren and i do a review
together
um just go watch it come back and tell
us what you thought
we love to hear what you guys think
and that's what we've had the most fun
with with these watch parties are um
being able to hear what you guys think
and we don't want you to just
regurgitate what we say all the time
yeah um
because
otherwise we're all the same
yeah yeah yeah yeah so and yeah guys it
is woof woof w-o-o-f
fun fact though
it really started off as w-o-l-f
it's like i was pronouncing wolf
wolf
i was saying wolf
he just struggles i can't say the word
unless i really focus on it like if i
just talk and i say woof like it's woof
and that's how that started like
it started by me saying the white wolf
which is who buddy becomes an infinity
war right or super early on first credit
scene of black panther
and i said white wolf
and i have to think about it but i was
just talking so i said white wolf
and people were like
you say woof i was like do i and i
listen back and i'm like i do i can't
like when i'm just casually talking i
can't say the l
so
yeah
um
i've seen a few people ask me about
gaming today
why i don't start a gaming channel
because it's just so much time
like it's so much time we do we do a lot
of work guys
yeah like
it's hard to do stuff like that and then
it's just the two of us and then when
you
and then when you
when you take something because like i
used to stream on twitch
and it took the fun of gaming from me
also true
and i didn't like that so i stopped
streaming on twitch because gaming is
something i would do for fun to just
like hang out with my friends and stuff
um
and that's kind of why i don't start a
gaming channel because like yeah i play
some games with my friends i'm not a pro
at anything by any means whatsoever i'm
not good enough not sure
you can watch me rage in fortnite if
that's what that's always
because that's not really what ends up
happening no i'm not playing
i'm not i'm not playing valerian again
those were the times though
yeah
hey happy for live watch parties to be
back looking forward to videos but
serious also this episode may be a huge
sum for captain carter not gonna lie for
real right captain carter is pretty cool
not gonna lie and uh
yeah it was pretty cool it's almost cool
to see that transformation
yeah kinda like she is she was jacked up
yes blackpink thank you
people i'm just happy to have content i
did enjoy the show and i'm excited to
see how it builds because they always
get better as they go the episode wasn't
even that bad seven out of seven point
five out of ten from ashley ashley beau
ashley hello
bo
thank you for sharing that
i think disney plus has enhanced our
experience
i think these shows are a lot of fun i
think the movies are going to be bigger
events that are going to be a lot more
fun to go to it's not going to be like
oh well here's iron man 3 everybody
let's get to the theater because it's a
marvel movie we have to
movies are going to be bigger
better and crazy and then these disney
plus shows give us an opportunity to
really dive into these characters so we
can avoid getting you know
falcon in the winter soldier movie
number three we just need a season and
we really dive into it i think it's a
lot a lot of fun personally
i well and if you think about it this
way
before we were getting
three marble movies a year
now look how much we have
like there's so much content it's gonna
be
wait
wait one division started this year
and started at the end of last year into
this year right but it was part of this
year so that's yeah it was part of this
year falcon and the winter soldier
and miss marvel and hawkeye are probably
going to be this year too is maurice
marvel going to be this is what they're
thinking so that's i don't think it will
where would it go
uh
november
there's only five weeks between this and
hawkeye maybe it's only five okay we'll
take that away we'll do five and then
and then
black widow
eternal spider-man no way home am i
messing with oh my gosh guys
yes um um um no you said eternals that's
it that's it and then multiverse
abandons kicks off like what february
march
it's right around the corner after that
i think miss marvel will be like january
so that's that's nine projects in a year
and since the disney plus shows are so
spread out it's like literally the whole
entire year all year with small breaks
and that's fun that's gonna be how it is
from now on so i think
for years to come yeah we're not gonna
have
what was i was reading the other day
an article that they've already got like
six or seven new disney plus shows that
they haven't even announced yet lined up
oh yeah yeah yeah kevin feige said
he said
of everything we've announced
we have five
years five or six years plus
planned that we haven't announced
so it's like they've announced like four
years of the future which means they
have like 10 years planned which is
crazy
yeah
kim says hawkeye is my favorite avenger
nice kim
well
your favorite og avenger who's my
favorite og avenger oh i already know
the answer but just to share to the
people oh thor
thor
i love mr thor
mine was probably iron man at the time i
don't know if it's still the same but i
always like when they were doing all the
originals iron man movie came out i was
so stoked
and then as the avengers all started to
form i always loved iron man
i was always a huge wolverine fan
well yeah wolverine was cool but he's
not an avenger
um
i i i was always a huge wolverine fan
since i can remember i have a picture of
me dressing up as well brain's a little
kid i don't even know how old i am
as a little kid i was a big old
spider-man nerd because i was just in
that age i was too big because the
show was really that's why it was shows
were great they were hilarious wolverine
fan because the x-men right that was
huge
was it no what was the show called
uncanny no
comic
i can't remember but then as i started
reading the comics actually became his
deadpool nerd
i have like three deadpool comics like
right here behind me
i uh
it's cool to see all this stuff
happening it's cool to see marvel try
something different because i like that
too yeah you know a lot of people were
talking about
oh marvel is just the same thing over
and over again i think phase four has
proved differently
um i think one division was very
different
the whole which aspect i really liked
somebody said
um tell warren his volume is very low i
can hear him better on my channel than
on his that's fine that means people
come here to listen to him on my channel
uh
i don't really know how to fix that i
think that's what they said maybe just
turn me down a little bit man shut up
chris why you talking so loud i'll never
stop talking all right
all right
i i tried to
switch some things up anyways um
yeah wolverine is badass yeah
wolverine's the best um
i forgot i was talking about
we're talking about um marvel doing
something new oh yeah one division was
great because it was the witches i think
falcon felt very mcu
uh
and then loki was just like
blew my expectations away loki was
incredible um
like truly and black widow was very mcu
because she is you know mcu so
i really think
marvel's trying to do different i think
multiverse madness is going to be crazy
we all know about spider-man um
yeah i think
we're gonna talk i think we're in for
i think we're in for
uh for a fun time um
how tall am i
five eight
is that right chris how tall is alex
five seven i'm five seven
he's the same height i can never
remember if i'm five seven or five eight
i met i met warren before i met my wife
so when i met warren and we got so close
like you know what
i need my wife to be as much as warren
like warren as possible yeah
same height
somebody said oh my gosh i love you too
so much oh i think that episode was
pretty good can't wait for the rest yeah
the next two episodes are you're gonna
enjoy them they're fun they're a lot of
fun and i think that's how most of us
should look at this going into it you
know i think
marvel's not as bad as star wars fans
but we are getting to the point where we
are getting a little toxic
as a fan base
and i think we need to take one step
back with this what f series and just
kind of enjoy it and have fun with it
take it in for what it is yeah just have
fun what if we had fun for a bit
yeah yeah
i am short yes i'm short warren is a
little short i'm six foot nobody asked
me but i'll i'll volunteer that shut up
chris
i'm six foot tall yeah
thank you for that super chat and gc
nightwalker
was the tentacle interdimensional thing
she mcgorith or something equivalent
just a random thought no i i think it's
she mcgorth i that's what we were doing
but i don't know
what else it could be like
especially within marvel you know yeah i
don't know what canon item that already
exists it could have been i was saying
it could have been like some weird hydra
thing what did they call it the champion
of hydra
that's what he called it yes
i think he's like the champion of hydra
is here and then he came in and crushed
him like immediately which was yeah
because you can't control the
mcgorth
can't control it all um hawkeye and miss
marvel uh i'm excited for hawkeye and
miss marvel
i'm more excited now after black widow
yeah yeah yeah i'm curious to see how
that's i guess i won't talk spoilers
just in case but i'm excited to see how
that works out the story uh with what
happened at the end of black widow um
i'm excited for haley
uh yeah yeah she's gonna do a good job
time field seinfeld
to enter us go say hayley williams i'm
like that's the lead singer
uh i'm excited for haley steinfeld to
enter the mcu and become like the new
hawkeye i think it's gonna be really
cool i'm excited to see a little bit
more ronin action
um
i i think it's gonna maybe be a little
bit you know it's inhumans but
maybe get some mutant action going on so
i'm excited to see what what goes on
there i think there's a bunch of
different ways they could take that
story so
william
lucking what if marvel studios got the
rights back to sparta man spider-man
truly enjoyed the channel thank you so
much william uh man you know i
i think i think they push for that a lot
right but sony's not budging uh i think
no i don't think so i think they've
offered them a crap ton of money like i
think they've offered them money and so
you wonder what the conversations behind
doors have been about that i'm sure
they've been some pretty crazy numbers
thrown at him yeah me and chris joke all
the time that kevin feige's like
freaking sony like these freaking guys
like
what was it we were going to do a video
having feige over for dinner and talking
about all right
like having kevin feige over to my house
for like dinner and like you know one of
us pretend to be feige and just like
how's it going
oh i'm super stressed out sony's really
giving it to me
i had the red button pushed months ago
they said no we have to wait
oh
tim
wonder
good point
in case anybody was wondering the
majority of ortonized conversations are
essentially what you're watching here
pretty much
um tim wonder good point so now who's
going to lead everyone to the soul stone
in that particular universe
yeah
somebody will do it did he maybe he will
but he died but he did get pulled into
the portal
yeah so
yeah
how hard is it for you to not talk about
spoilers do you actually have to sign
stuff like reveal anything and marvel
sends a hit squad yes uh
we do and then anything they send us has
our
so like if you shared a screenshot or
anything it's literally right in the
middle like it's literally right you can
actually see it on my twitter i did post
a picture of the logo when loki came out
says i was all excited because you know
that was one of my first projects i did
with him as a press and i thought it
would be okay to post that but it says
chris m rosser right in the middle yeah
so it's literally your name is like
my name's big warren g thompson like
it's big
so it's like right across the entire
screen it's kind of cool but it's also a
little scary it's like yeah it's uh
and it's been funny because like some of
my family members have been like hey can
we like
can we watch the screen i'm like no like
no like no you cannot that's a link
because it's through like this company
they use right i think the company is
actually called digital screeners
and you have to log in and enter your
password and all the stuff then they
send you like a code to your phone and
you have to do all this other stuff and
then you say like you sign all this
stuff right i agree with this but well i
agree with this
if i do this i get sued blah blah blah
like it's it's it's a lot of legal stuff
that you do have to check before each
time you watch a screener anytime you
log in
yeah uh bumblebee thanks for the super
chat uh because that's the whole premise
of what if you know um
one small thing affects the universe
completely and in a completely different
way so
i believe
all these events led to
yeah yeah okay so all these events led
to
shield keeping the tesseract
and never went under in the ice and
stuff like that so right i don't think
they had control
i don't think thanos would have ever got
it and look he would have ever gotten it
so that's why uh captain carter comes
out
chris you and warren should make a song
we'll get it on the charts
oh no we've we've made a song
yeah we should make a real one though
what's it gonna be how is that not a
real song i put my life into it we did
put 24 hours of 24 hours
exhaustion
yeah uh
loki's in the third episode
and it's pretty cool
so yeah
um
yeah
so
but all right guys i'm beat i have to we
got some work
i was sitting here thinking like wow we
went a little longer than we're supposed
to but it's kind of nice because
it's good conversation i like that i
always love the chats
i love chatting with everybody yeah
i have watched agent carter and somebody
had to remind me in the chat that that
guy was from agent carter uh flynn i
don't remember if it's sergeant flynn or
it's john flynn
curious how he like why they decided to
throw him in here
but yeah um i'm sure
peggy could lift me on there she seems
like she's she seems like she's pretty
great she really does so all right
that's another that's another what if
question maybe we'll start making our
own
yeah
that'd be fun
yeah yeah okay
everybody again asking about my hair
i bleached it
because i'm dying it a different color
and i had to bleach it to diet that
color it wants to look more like me
yeah
so it'll change soon probably next week
it'll be a different color
so all right guys this is awesome this
is great as always um if you haven't
subscribed
subscribe to chris this guy on my screen
like and subscribe over at cosmic
culture
don't forget it go over there once you
throw a little link in the in the chat
let me grab a little link for you boy
jim x mafia what's up with the super
chat what if roadie playing an in-game
work like the one to kill thanos
yeah
copyright that one i think that uh
the way
they did time travel it wouldn't have
worked but
sure would have stayed a lot of problems
i think if you're wondering about that
question you'll like the next episode of
what if i think i think people will like
the next episode of what if
hey hey mr anderson nice i think mr
anderson got you
oh thanks i'ma do it too yeah because i
want to feel like i'm useful
oh he's way ahead of me he's way ahead
of me
oh yeah he beat you to it boom all right
go go go best mod all right guys
subscribe to chris if you haven't he
does similar content to mine it's really
good
legendary phoenix hideout what's up just
so you came in we're getting off hope
everybody has a great night uh we're
gonna work on this breakdown right now
love you all three thousand
and hope to see you
hope to see you here next week so bye
guys